Um, Leex, are you a Muslim? Yes, I am.
Can you hear me? Hello? Yes, I can hear
you. Welcome. All right. So, I'm just
here to ask you one simple question
about Christianity that nobody was able
to answer me. I've met You have to first
deal with the topic. What What topic?
The topic is where is Muhammad in the
NGO? If you can answer that cuz I've as
been asking this for three years now
that I've been public and not a single
Muslim has been able to answer this
question for me. It looks like both of
us are in a bind. Okay, let me be clear
with you. I am not a Muslim scholar. I'm
just a guy who know the basics about
Islam. But I'm here to ask you this
question about Christianity. You don't
think that this is a basic question? Cuz
this for me proves that the Quran is
telling the truth because it says
Muhammad's mentioned in the So if I can
find him in the Quran's true. No, the
thing is I've never studied this deeply.
So I can't say things out of my mind
when I didn't even study it. I could
literally give you a wrong answer. So
that's the point. So all right, let me
ask you this then. As far as where I
stand since I can't find Muhammad
anywhere in the NGO, am I am I in the
right to to conclude that the Quran is
false? Well, as I told you, if I did my
own research to see if this is a false
or true, then I would tell you, oh,
listen, you prove that the that that
Islam is false, right? But if it was
wrong, then you got it wrong. I'm saying
I I'm saying I've done my research. I've
looked into the NGL. I've looked into
the words of Jesus and stuff and nowhere
do I ever see Muhammad being mentioned
or described. So, am I am I right to
conclude that the Quran is false for
making this false claim? See, here's the
problem. You say that and I see others
showing and proving that Muhammad is in
jail. So, which one should I believe,
you or them? I've seen so many. Let's
let's put it to the test. What What have
you seen? I've seen so many videos on
YouTube showing and proving that
Muhammad was was mentioned here and
there. There were there was so many
videos I don't even remember them. Like
I have to search them up. It was a long
time ago. You know, do do me this favor.
Look that up really quick and I want you
to um cuz I won't kick you. I'll let you
stay here. Okay. I'm going to bring up
somebody in in in in the place. Yeah.
Okay. I want you to look this up. look
at some YouTube videos and then bring
their video or their that argument to me
and let's let's see if their argument
stands. Fair enough. I bet give me two
minutes. Okay. And you can come off mute
whenever you want. Okay. I'm I'm going
to mute your mic, but you can unmute
whenever you're ready. Okay. I was
searching the whole internet, right? And
I couldn't find a single verse that says
Muhammad is going to be the next prophet
or or anything like that. But I found a
verse. It's saying in detrronomi. I
don't know how to pronounce that. Uh
Deuteronomy 18:8.
Yeah. Yeah. This one. That's the only
thing that I have found. You see, I've
never studied this deeply. So, I've seen
different opinions. So, I don't know
which one to believe, but I truly want
to ask you as a Christian who knows more
better about Christianity. I I want to
know about this verse more. So, can I
ask you the verse? Deuteronomy 18:18.
No, no, not this verse. There's another
verse that I wanted to ask you. This is
why I came on stage. Okay. Before I let
you ask this off-topic question because
it is off my topic. Yeah. Is it can you
acknowledge that be if I can't find
Muhammad anywhere in the Torah in the um
then I am I am in my right to conclude
that the Quran is false. Okay. Does the
Quran say that the Bible predicted
Muhammad? Yes.
Where does it say that? Chapter 7 verse
157. Chapter 7 verse
157. Okay, I'm looking at this. Wait a
second. Hello. Hello. Um, okay. Oh,
yeah. You're right. You're right. It it
actually says that. But the thing is,
um, we have to also know that the Bible
was changed and corrupt. Corrupted. So,
no, I'm just being honest with you. It's
okay. Tech, I I'm about to deal with him
for a while. Just just hold on a second.
That's fine. That's good. Okay. Yeah,
that's good. Go ahead. All right. So, so
Lev, you said that the Bible's been
changed. Yeah. So, if the Bible's been
changed, let me ask you this. When do
you think that the Bible was changed?
Was it changed before Muhammad's time or
do you think it was changed after? Wait,
that's a good question. Wait, was it
before or after? Mhm. If you had to give
a guess, I believe it was changed. What
if it's after Muhammad? If it's after
before before. Okay. I think it was it
was changed before. That's what I think.
Got it. All right. So, it's changed
before Muhammad's time. So, by the time
Muhammad comes, the Bible's already been
corrupted and changed. Yeah. Yeah. Okay.
Now, how does this make sense when the
Quran says that they in Muhammad's time
that they can find him mentioned in the
Torah and the Gospel that's with them?
See when the inj and the Torah was
revealed to the prophets it was not
corrupted right but later on later on it
was corrupted and Muhammad came to tell
I mean the Quran was revealed to
Muhammad and the Quran tells us what
happened in the past and what it was
telling us in the past is that it was
mentioned in the injil or the Torah
right no it doesn't say in the past it
doesn't say in the past because it says
it's with them currently but The but the
Quran tells us stories and explains to
explains to us what happened before.
Yeah. In what books? What do you mean
what books? What books say that these
stories these stories or prophecies are
in? What books? The Torah and the
Gospel, right? Yeah. Yeah. The Torah.
Yeah. And according to the Quran,
according to the verse you just read,
7157, where is the Injil in Muhammad's
time? Where is it? Wait, I don't know
what you're trying to Wait, can you
explain to me more in a clear way?
Because I've told you before, I'm not a
Muslim scholar. So this is why. So look,
what what we're doing here, what I'm
what I'm doing is I'm making you think
about what you say, okay? And I'm
showing you how what you say, it's not
just you. Like this is actually the
usual Muslim response. So you're not
different. And I'm showing you how the
usual Muslim response does not make
sense, whether it's historically or even
from a Quranic standpoint. Okay? So if
you're going to say that the scripture,
yeah, Muhammad was mentioned in the
Torah and the Gospel. However, the Torah
and Gospel have been changed. When were
they changed? They were changed before
Muhammad's time. So before Muhammad came
on the scene, they had already been
corrupted. That's when Muhammad came.
Okay, cool. So Muhammad before his time,
but when he comes, the Quran, the Torah
and the Gospel is already corrupted. But
then it's interesting because the Quran
says in Muhammad's time, chapter 7,
verse 157, it says that the Torah and
Gospel still have Muhammad's description
in there. And the it's with the Jews and
Christians. It's with them. They have
it. It's not lost. It's there. They can
open it up and find Muhammad's
description. That's what the Quran
claims. So, okay. Yeah. This would have
to mean that the Torah and Gospel that's
there at Muhammad's time is not
corrupted because they can find Muhammad
in there. Can I um Okay, but the thing
Okay, I'm sorry. Can I answer? Me or
him? No, we can both answer. Just you go
first. Okay, so you said the usual
Muslim answers. The thing is there's
probably Muslims out there that come to
your channel that are not well educated
enough about Islam very deeply. They
know the basics about Islam, but they
are not educated about this. And I'm
being honest with you. I've told I'm not
talking about I'm not talking about
ignorant Muslims. I'm talking about the
da guys that you see on YouTube and
Speaker's Corner. And have you debated
them? Yes. How many of them? All of them
except Muhammad Aab. I haven't spoken to
Muhammad Ajab yet. But everybody else
from Hamza's Den, everybody on there,
Ali Dawa, his shake, um Abu Anan son,
um Muslim, who else? What about What
about Shikhman? Shikhman. Yeah,
Shikhman. He was he was the first guy
that I debated. What about the Muslim
lantern? Oh, the Muslim lantern. He
kicked me off and and um copyrighted the
video whenever I tried to upload our
conversation, but it's uploaded on my
Patreon for free. So, if you want to
ever check that out, I'm actually going
to I'm going to watch your videos and
watch their videos to see and compare
like which one is the truth because if
there is anything that I want to know
which one is the right one, the true
one, I'm going to have to look it up and
research it. So, you know, I can't
really give you a direct answer because
I don't know which one is the true one.
Can I ask you the question off topic
about Christianity? I I will let you
because you're honest, but I I want us
to settle this first. I want you to get
this. What I want you to see is and tell
me if this makes sense. Does it make
sense to for the Quran to say that
Muhammad can be found in corrupted
scripture? Does that make sense to you?
Avery, can I answer that? No. I need May
I
I'll let you uh I'll let you jump in on
this in a second. Tech, I just want to
hear I want to hear him. So far, you
said no. Okay, but no, but what if the
Quran was like telling us that he was
mentioned in the scriptures that were
not corrupted, but later on they were
corrupted. Ah, so that would mean that
the scriptures were corrupted after
Muhammad's time, not before. This is
confusing. Yes. Yes. After Muhammad.
Okay. So if they're corrupted after
Muhammad, this still works in my favor.
Want to know why? Because Muhammad is in
the seventh century, right? Yeah. So
that means that all I need besides a
beat that's super dumping is a Bible
that dates to Muhammad's time and
before, not after. If I have manuscripts
of the gospel that are at least in the
7th century and before, I'm good to go.
I have the uncorrupted gospel. Yeah,
which I do. The gospels that I have come
from the second, 3rd, fourth, fifth,
6th, 7th century and beyond and beyond.
And you did not find Muhammad there. And
Muhammad is not in there, bro. This
that's what we have in the Bible. The
Bible is the you know that the Bible we
have is based off manuscripts in the
second century, 3rd century, fourth,
fifth, sixth, seventh. We have all of
that. I mean, I've seen videos saying
that his name was mentioned as Ahmed and
stuff or some other verses just describe
describing him only, not mentioning his
name. Yeah. This this what I want you to
do. Um, and I want you to come back on
this on this as well. Okay? Cuz I want
to talk to us again cuz you're pretty
honest and humble. I want you to look at
like look this up. Look at what the the
Dies the Dawa guys say. Look at what
Shikuman says. Whoever you find some
good videos that you think, "Oh, okay. I
I see you know where they make this
argument. Um and even if it's not
convincing you like bring it write it
down. Write down the take notes on it
and bring it to me and let's talk about
if what they're saying lines up if it
makes sense and I'll show you how
they're picking and choosing and how the
scriptures that they go to actually
backfire against them. I'll show you
that. Okay. Wait, when do you when do
you stream later? I'm I'm stream every
Monday, Wednesday, and Friday. Same
time. Oh, okay. every Monday, Wednesday
or Friday. So, anytime catch me any
Monday, Wednesday, Friday, I'm live.
I'll remember you, Lin
Lin Le, I'll remember. And uh come up
and we'll we'll continue. Okay. Thank
you, man. But now I have I have I have a
Christian friend and we've been talking
a lot and he did couldn't answer this
question for me. So, this is why when I
saw you streaming, I'm like, "Okay, I'm
going to ask him this question. Maybe he
will able to explain it." So, can I can
I go for it? Yeah. Okay. And by the way,
tech, don't forget what you wanted to
jump in and say, okay? Cuz I'm going to
let you address the argument after he's
done. Okay.
Okay. Okay. So, the verse is First
Samuel 15:3, right? I'm Yes. I'm
probably sure that you know about it. Do
you know the verse or should I read it?
Yeah. Where God commands them to unalive
everyone. Kids, donkeys, animals, men,
women. Now, maybe you could unalive men.
Maybe you could unalive other type of
creatures, but how can
God allow the death to infants and
children, babies who are like a few
months old, one year old, who doesn't
know what's right and what's wrong and
have never committed any type of sins.
And by the way, why is it allowed to
kill the animals? So like cattle and
donkeys and sheeps, like what did they
do? What did they do for them to get
killed? You know, if he's a merciful
God, why would he allow something like
this? Okay, so to answer your question
about the Amalachites, the
Amalachites, there's a reason why God
has a grudge against them. The
Amalachites when God brought them out,
brought the Israelites out of Egypt, you
know that story, right? Where he saved
them from Ferron and brought them out of
Egypt. I don't know 100% of it, but I've
heard about it. Okay, it's okay. So,
basically, the Israelites were enslaved
in Egypt for over 400 years. God sent
Moses, his messenger, right? And God
saved the Israelites from bondage, from
slavery. Okay? And then they were going
to go from Egypt to the promised land
that God had promised to give to the
Israelites that he promised to give to
Abraham, Isaac, and Jacob long before.
Okay? So God is fulfilling his promise.
Now, on the way to the promised land,
the Amalachites attacked the Israelites.
He attacked them. The Amalachites
attacked them when they were weak,
hungry, attacked them from behind,
attacked the women, attacked the old
men, and so tried to wipe out Israel.
And so, um, they didn't succeed
obviously, but God said in vengeance, he
says that he in turn is going to wipe
out the Amalachites, going to wipe them
from the face of the earth. Everything
that they are and everything that they
own is going to be gone. So what we have
here, what you're seeing is the fruition
of that commandment or that uh that
decree that God's judgment on the
Amalachites. Just like how he decreed to
wipe them out, he chooses, you know,
that this is the time to wipe them out
cuz they continued to be rebellious.
They were never repented. They continued
to be rebellious and fight against God's
people. So he decided to um bring his
judgment on them, the entire nation, and
wipe them out. Okay? Dunkeys and all,
everything they own. Now, here's also
something interesting because you want
to take this into cultural context. In
cultural context, when it came to like
war language,
um uh when you when you would say like
um like for example, if you say if I
were to say, uh man, blow them out of
the water, right? you know, something
like that. If I'm going against another
another team or another I'm in battle,
I'm not literally saying that they're in
water, I'm going to blow them out the
water. No, but it means to like wipe
them out, like completely destroy them,
right? Like win, right? But
convincingly, right? Um, and you see
this language in the Bible as well, like
when it talks about wipe them
completely. I wipe them from the face of
the earth, man, woman, child, and
everything like that. Destroy them all.
Kill them all. Right? But you'll see
some of these people are still alive and
still around and even intermingling with
the Israelites. You'll see that this is
length. This is common war language. Um,
you know, communicating to completely
destroy your opponent. So, it's not
necessarily that every kid is being
killed or every woman is being killed.
Everything is being killed, but they are
being completely defeated, utterly
destroyed. So, that's kind of war
language there. Okay. Wait, so they
didn't kill the babies, the entire
babies of the Amaz that's that's a view.
There there's a view that that that's
like the interpretive view that using
this war language, it's not that the
babies are being killed or even, you
know, everybody's being killed,
everything's being killed, but it's the
language to just destroy them and wipe
them out. Now, I don't have a problem
with God's judgment on the Amalachites
of wiping out the entire nation,
including the children. I don't have a
problem with that. God, you know, can do
what he decides to do, you know. Um, but
there is a interpretation that that's
it's hyperbolic language, you know, it's
hyperbolic in meaning to destroy or wipe
out your opponent. Doesn't necessarily
necessarily mean that you kill every
single soul, right? However, let me let
me let me put this to you, okay? In
reverse. You believe in the flood story,
right? About the Pharaoh, right? The
flood. No, no. Yes. The flood. Which
which one is it? Which prophet was it?
Noah. No. Noah. Yeah. Yeah. I know it.
Noah. Yeah. So, God flooded the world,
drowned everyone except Noah and his
family. Right. And the animals and the
people that was with him on the ark. And
Exactly. Everybody else that was not
with him on the ark, man, woman or child
and beast was drowned in the flood.
Yeah.
So even from the Quran standpoint, you
have Allah giving a judgment that
includes the children of the
disbelievers of the of the sinful that
God g Allah gives a judgment on the
nation. Meaning this one the entire
world he judges all of them and whoever
is not on that boat including the
children are drowned. They don't
survive. Okay, you're actually right
about this one. The point is Allah never
mentioned that like even the childrens
are going to drown. And the other thing
is he says he says he says everyone
that's not on this boat. Everyone that's
not on this boat with you is drowned.
Everyone. Yes, you're right. But I've
also heard that Allah might have drowned
the people of Noah or the entire earth.
He can't drown the people of Noah if
people of Noah are on the boat. No,
that's not what I'm saying. I'm saying
like only the people of Noah. He didn't
drown the whole Oh, that that entire
nation. No, no. Only the people of Noah.
He drown He didn't drown the whole world
when it comes to that. The entire nation
that Noah that Noah was living in that
that entire nation that was flooded,
right? Yeah. Right. So, everyone that's
in that's part of that nation, man,
woman, and child that wasn't on that
boat got drowned. That still doesn't
solve the issue because you still have
children being drowned in that nation.
You're actually so out about this. I
have to research this up. Yeah. But the
thing is it was never mentioned that
there was children in the nation. So
like Yeah. To to think that there's an
entire nation without without kids is
crazy. No, because people people back
then used to live like thousands of
years, right?
They No, they didn't use they didn't
live thousand years. They they lived
quite a few hundreds. They lived
hundreds of years. Like Noah lived, I
think, to about 600 years, I think. And
uh so they were living hundreds of
years, bro. And you mean to tell me that
an entire nation where people are living
hundreds of years are not having
hundreds of kids? Wait a second. So in
Islam, Noah lived 1,000 years, but in
Christianity, he lived 600, right? Yeah,
he lived 600. In Islam, Noah lived a
thousand. That's crazy. That's awesome.
Okay, cool. That that's that's even
better. You got Noah living a thousand
years. So we can probably you know
assume that there's others living at a
similar amount of time uh you know you
know up to 800 600 900 a thousand who
who knows right they're living hundreds
of years up to a thousand of course
they're having children in this nation
bro yes they are you're right about this
but but my question is the when it come
when we come back to the to to the verse
of the Amalocites was it a language war
or was it an order, a direct order from
God. Yeah. So you it's it's an order
from God to wipe out the Amalachites.
But however, God in in his language,
bro, he uses hyperbole. It's hyperbolic
language. All all, you know, he does it
often. He says wipe out a certain
nation, you know, yet there's still
people from that nation still alive and
and even integrating with Israel, right?
But they're as a nation, they're they're
done. They're destroyed. They have to
rely on Israel. So, you have that type
of language. It's like same thing if I'm
saying, man, you know, the New York
Knicks are going to wipe out the Indiana
Pacers, you know, that that means
they're going to win. They're going to
beat them in the playoff series, you
know.
Um, you know, inshallah. But um yeah,
this it's hyperbolic language. But
again, you like in both of our cases, we
have God sending down a judgment on a
nation that would include, you know,
even the children as well. God's
judgment is is his judgment. Yeah. See,
but the difference between these two
verses is that, you know, the children
were not mentioned, but the but when it
comes to the the verse in the Bible, the
children were mentioned. though. I don't
I don't think that if uh that's the
thing that didn't like it didn't make
sense to me like a merciful God would
order the killing of a pure baby that
could be you know for example you went
to theides yeah you you you he you heard
like there's there's no need for us to
like continue to rehash the same points
so you you you understand that during
the flood Allah wiped out an entire
nation except for the people that's on
the boat that would include the children
that's an entire nation you know so We
we both have judgments in which God
includes children at worst case
scenario. Even if what I'm saying is not
hyperbolic. Let's say it's God's
judgement. Okay. Okay. But we don't know
the age of children back then. Like were
they 10? Were they 12? Children, bro.
Children, babies, infants. They're born
every day. Children are born every day
in every nation even to this day. Okay.
But a 12year-old is is a different from
a one-year-old. So, okay fine. Let's
let's move on from this topic. What
about the mistakes in the Bible? Oh, no.
That's it. That was the one question you
had, right? But come back. Come back.
Come back next time and we'll continue
our talk on other stuff in the Bible
and in the Bible. Okay, cool. Next time
I will bring all the mistakes and I will
tell you about them and you know next
time we will we can have a conversation
about this. Bring bring the prophecies
of Muhammad in the Bible. What they say
where where they think Muhammad's
mentioned in the Bible. Oh yeah, I will
do that too. I will do that too. That
that's the main
You too, man. I can't wait to talk to
you again, bro. Man, have a nice day.